so
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
there ain't nothing
i can't do
or nothing i can say
that folks don't criticize me
but i'm going to do
just
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
just what people say
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
there
[Music]
wait
[Music]
i guess he fell for it
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Music]
no no no no no no
ah
hi everyone and welcome to the academy's
visiting artists film series filmmate
edition for film composers i'm tara
stenson and today i have the pleasure of
interviewing
the amazing chris bowers
hi tara good to see you good to see you
chris yeah thanks so much oh thank you
this is amazing um
moment i'm happy to i have so many
questions for you but so does everyone
else have to get in line
um i'm just going to jump right in um i
know that like a dream of mine growing
up was to go to juilliard but you
actually went there
and that's amazing i i know um i just
want to know a little bit about that um
you don't just wake up and decide to go
to juilliard so this must have been a
dream that was like brewing inside of
you for years um can you tell us a
little bit about that
yeah you know it's it's interesting i i
didn't actually decide that i wanted to
go to juilliard until
i had gotten past the first round of
auditions um
my parents decided before i was born
they wanted me to play piano and
they really
did a lot to make sure that they put me
in the best environments for music
education and they drove all over la to
find the best teachers and all this
stuff and i was you know studying piano
from the time i was four up until
all through high school and so i knew i
wanted to go to a conservatory but when
i was a junior i got in a full
scholarship to berkeley college of music
in boston and i told my parents like
that's where i'm going and there's no
conversation about it essentially
and they were concerned that um
it didn't feel like the the best
structure in their mind as far as a
school environment and they wanted
me to consider maybe going to usc or
going to
another school where i could i could
major in music but i could maybe minor
in something else or get like a
general education at the same time and
the idea of the conservatory was kind of
making them nervous and it was um
actually a teacher of mine and a mentor
named eric reed this amazing jazz
pianist who
suggested to me and to my parents that i
should look at juilliard and that was a
really great program and it also would
provide that structure that my parents
were looking for and so i did the first
audition and i was kind of uh like not
really that interested to be honest and
then i hadn't really looked at the
program and after i got
through that first audition process i
just looked deeper into the program and
realized that oh if i get in i'm one of
four
jazz pianists in the program and so the
the chances of me studying with kenny
barron or eric reid or whomever i want
to study with is much higher than if i
go to berkeley and i'm one of like
hundreds of pianists and if i want to
study with my favorite teacher that
might take me a few years to get there
so the idea of how small
that environment was and how familiar it
was especially because they had a
process where they only accepted
what they lost the previous year and so
it was a really big mix of years and
ages so my freshman year when i got
there the ensemble that i was in was
like you know me as a freshman and then
a couple of seniors and a couple of
masters students so it immediately puts
you in this this position where you have
to operate on the same level as all
these other players who are older than
you or more experienced and so once i
understood the program a bit more then
that became like the only school i
wanted to go to and so i just really
lucked out that in that second part of
the audition process i i ended up
getting in well that that is incredible
way to go mom and dad yeah that
foresight um so you
you study jazz there yeah yeah yeah i
want to know like about the transition
like from
from jazz to film scoring like was it
was
did you always want to score film or did
you want to be a big jazz
artist or what was your dream and are
you living your dream um there's like so
many parts of this question yeah my um
my parents like i mentioned as far as
their plan for me were very
serious about me also having a plan for
myself like they asked me when i was
like
when i was a freshman in high school my
dad was like okay well what's the plan
for college like what do you think you
want to do and like how what's the the
trajectory essentially
and uh at that time i had really fallen
in love with film music just because my
dad
was a writer for film and tv and so
movies
were just like you know
something that we gathered around you
know he always wanted to show us his
favorite films anytime a new movie came
out we were immediately there at the
theater to see that movie that weekend
and up until that point
piano had been this
medium of expression for me like once i
started learning jazz and improvisation
the thing that made me want to continue
to play piano and make it my thing was
the fact that it felt like a safe space
for me to express emotion and so
once i recognized that there was a job
where i literally could translate
emotion into music uh you know realizing
that i could listen to the score from
jurassic park and feel the same level of
adventure and excitement that i did when
i was watching the movie um i just told
my parents when my dad had that
conversation with me when i was like 12
i was like i would have i want to go to
college for jazz piano then i want to
tour with my favorite jazz artist and i
want to tour with my own jazz band and
then transition to film scoring and i
honestly like when i told him that plan
i was like yeah so maybe by the time i'm
like 40 i'll be getting into film
scoring essentially
it was just a combination of the fact
that like
i
one i think the touring life was just i
mean you know you know how it is like i
i just
yeah i got the first years i was like i
can't do this for like
20 years
and also
what was interesting is that some of my
first projects came from people who
heard me talk about that from that young
age like
i scored a documentary about kobe bryant
that was like one of my first projects
and that came because a friend of mine
who i was in a high school all-star jazz
band with uh came to me at a show here
in la with my band and we hadn't seen
each other since high school and he was
like man i remember
when we were in that band in high school
you mentioned wanting to be a film
composer and i'm producing this
documentary about kobe and i love your
music and i feel like you'd be great to
compose for it and wow so i feel like a
lot of those first opportunities really
just
came because i talked about that plan so
much that as soon as somebody thought oh
i need a composer they and recognize
that i wanted to do that they just kind
of helped uh help me
uh with that transition essentially one
other funny thing which is like a slight
connection for us is um
uh you know i know you obviously were
nominated for mudbound and reese
the first time that that happened where
somebody was like oh you want to be a
composer help me out was d reese's first
short film or a short film of hers when
i was in high school oh
i don't even know how i met her but she
asked me if i would score that film and
i was like yeah i want to and i got home
and i was like i have no idea what to do
i put the vhs in my vhs player and i was
like like what do i do
wow
like i'm sorry i can't score your film
and then she became d reeks and i was
like oh man
that's amazing and you know what we're
going to have to short and shorten that
uh six degrees of separation and work
together one of these days that's that's
amazing yeah that year i remember
meeting kobe and just like
yeah icon how was it working with him
man yeah it was amazing i mean he he
actually has had a huge impact on
my
mentality my life my approach to film
scoring so i worked with him on that
documentary
but also um one with that documentary
what was interesting is that when i
brought when i was brought on the
director was like you know we're
pretty much done we have a rough cut
we're going to show it to kobe and then
we'll just kind of edit it together and
then
or make the final edits and then add the
music and we'll be done and
they showed it to kobe and kobe was like
this is unacceptable and made them start
over from scratch essentially
and i was already on the team and so he
just included me in the process of like
building this film from the from the
ground up and so i saw them
put it together and saw him kind of
guiding that process and learning about
film along the way and so i was learning
a lot at the same time watching him but
he would often one of the things he told
me that still sticks with me in our
first meeting was that um
he was like watch this film and and look
at all these experiences in my life but
think about
uh emotional moments in your own life
that are parallel to these things for me
and right from that place from your
personal emotional place and it's going
to be great and wait that was his advice
to you yeah yeah oh like wow
yeah that's incredible he um and he was
always like you know pushing me to write
the best music possible and i ended up
working on uh he wrote these audio or
these uh children's books and i scored
the audiobooks for those and
working on like his his you know
documentary about his final season so i
actually had a conversation with him
like literally a week before he passed
because we were still working together
on projects and but he was constantly
helping me think about how i could
approach my craft in in the best way
possible and from different ways and it
also helps that like he is a huge john
williams fan and actually used to call
john williams like a couple times a year
like a few times a year they would just
chat about process so oh just icon icon
hello
it's like i wish i could be like just
listening to those conversations wow
that that that is incredible um so kobe
also had like this um
huge impact on on children and and and
like a
service i feel like um maybe you know
connected to his daughter and uh just
wanting to i feel like he would have
mentored you know um as he was mentoring
you um in in this program
um we had these children from kenya
and now you have a chance to
give some advice and answer some
questions and and and actually like i
know there's a lot of dreamers that have
because i look at these questions and
there's these are kids that know what
they want and they just need to know how
to get there um and so i i don't i have
so many questions i don't want to be
unfair so
i want to make sure that we get to the
questions um
from the kids in kenya
um
and
so the first question is at what phase
of the filmmaking process do you like to
come to a project
that's a great question i feel like
for me
it's as early as possible
so that i can get a clear understanding
of the story it's also really
the story and the characters
and it's really interesting to see how
that continues to develop over time
because there are times where
they start to hone in on on specific
themes or you know as they're
working on the edit of a film i start to
realize like oh some of these other
pieces are falling away because they're
not as important or you know uh they're
trying to figure out what the heart of
the movie is
uh as they're working on it and so if
i'm along the ride in that process i can
kind of see what the music should be
really pointing to with that as well
so i feel like the earlier the better
just because we can have a lot of
conversations about
about what they're wanting the music to
really underline and emphasize in the in
the storytelling and in the experience
with these characters but also i feel
like it allows for that trial and error
period because if i come in too late uh
really we're just trying to you know get
it right and and
if you don't have that much time as you
know to get it right it's like you're
often times uh doing something that's
somewhat expected or doing something
that comes easy or trying to get it done
quickly
but it's hard to do things that are out
of the box if you don't have that much
time and i love when i have a lot of
time early on to try things and and fail
and like directors have really
encouraged me to like
really experiment and if we don't you
know get it right with that
experimentation that's okay because that
experimentation might lead us down
somewhere else and and all that so
having time to have that
sandbox period for me is really
important so earlier the better
yeah i agree um and this question i
think this person probably already has a
job in film because they wouldn't
directors might get too attached to temp
music i call it temp itis
[Laughter]
and they um so the tip music that they
use during the edit how do you introduce
something new to them
yeah i mean
this person already knows right
but it is
right for those of you that don't know
that temp music is the temporary music
that's being put in as they're editing
and trying to figure out what the sound
of the movie is and they take music from
other films and put it in there um and
for me i feel like a lot of that's a
conversation
with the director to earn that trust
because really the temp has created this
safety uh where they know that this
music is hitting the emotion that they
want to hit and if i can try and
have conversations with them that can
unlock what it is that they like about
it you know now there are some directors
that it's difficult because they're
they're maybe struggling with how to
have that conversation and so for them
it's like i like to attempt whatever you
got to do to make it feel like that and
you know it becomes a more difficult job
and for me when when i'm put in that
position i maybe do that process myself
where i'm looking at what maybe is most
effective about this temp is it the
instrumentation is it the pace is it
moments that it's hitting is it like you
know uh the key and like the frequency
or is it like you know those kinds of
things that might be
worth borrowing from the attempt to then
build my own thing but any director
that's able to
have a conversation about why is this
temp making making you feel that way uh
you know i worked a lot with
ava uh and when we talk about temp it's
really amazing because she talks about
the emotion behind it where she'll say
you know this temp is making me feel
this way in these moments and so that
way
i know that as long as i hit these
moments in a similar
way emotionally it doesn't have to be
the same instrumentation or any of that
or you know borrowing too much from it
but if we can understand
why it's hitting those beats and how
it's making her feel
then i can kind of deduce what might be
doing that and try my own version of
that that's that's very helpful uh
because sometimes it's just like oh yeah
well i just want here's beyonce and this
is just what you know for me as a
songwriter and i don't know why and so
having those
asking those questions makes it easier
for me to say well you know what what is
it that you got from this how does it
make you feel what is there a lyric is
there you know is there is the key is
that the emotions the way she's singing
it so that's yeah i totally agree i
never thought there's temp with songs i
didn't even think about that god and
sometimes
especially because you know
the kinds of songs that i write there's
usually like one song that they use all
the time and i'll tell you off camera
because
why but i'm like oh okay here we go
and i'm like i know this emotion so i
don't know that's a good i guess it's a
good thing yeah yeah i know you can hit
it yeah yeah
absolutely um so what's the most
creative technique you've been able to
bring to your film career and process
that's a really good question
i feel like for me it's my background as
an improviser and as an accompanist just
because
the thing i've always loved about being
a jazz pianist is that you operate in
these two spaces where sometimes you're
the lead performer especially if you
have a trio or you're playing solo piano
but most often you're an accompanist
where you're trying to figure out how to
make these harmonies
support the singer or support the
horn player or whatever and especially
when those people are improvising you're
trying to figure out how to you know
fill in the holes or how to uh you know
do something that's going to make what
they're doing make
sense or contextualize what's happening
you know and so for me i approach film
scoring the same way where
i'll watch a scene over and over again
without anything
and often try to figure out what the
emotion is that we're trying to get at
based on the conversation with the
director and based on what i'm seeing
and then i go to the piano and improvise
to try to find something that feels like
it is getting me to a similar emotion
and then i just kind of play along to
the screen as if i'm accompanying
something but it's
nice to be able to you know move around
and not have to think about and not have
to write something out like i can sit
behind a scene over and over again and
just try a bunch of different things and
try a bunch of different changes um and
then
i'm also thinking in that accompanist
way where
there might be moments where i'm like oh
i want to leave a hole for that line or
i want to emphasize that line or i want
to make a shift under that line and you
know i'm really treating it like i'm the
dialogue and the sound is another
set of instruments that i'm playing
behind
and that improvisation also was
incredibly helpful
in this crazy industry as you know of
like you know
changing their minds at the last minute
where there were times at a recording
session where director's like you know
what i actually never really liked that
moment can we try something else right
yeah that's easy
like being able to make those changes
quickly and not have to worry too much
and just being able to trust my
instincts on on improvisation have been
really really valuable yeah
yeah that's yeah agreed um so this this
i had this question as well uh someone
asked when did you realize that you'd
like to apply your classical training to
a film career
because one of my
what i noticed is that your over time
your scores have become a bit more
classical
and so yeah so i i want to ask that
question too
yeah i appreciate that i think that
you know it's something i've always
dreamt about because the film music i
fell in love with even
at the same time as i was falling in
love with all the jazz records i was
falling in love with like you know oscar
peterson or wynton kelly or miles davis
herbie hancock like i was also listening
mostly to john williams or howard shore
named student howard or like these
composers that
like i definitely had also a huge love
and soft spot for terence blanchard and
composers that were using jazz elements
in their scores but when i thought of
film scoring i thought of john williams
or i thought of like these movies that
were like shaping my childhood and so
you know i i always dreamt of
trying to get more into that that type
of space and and you know as you were
just kind of saying it's really
interesting to kind of navigate
when you're
known for something you know when people
come to you for that thing and i
remember
my first couple of
projects um
it was
i was just very fortunate to have
directors that took a chance on me doing
something else because i remember
my first few meetings i would go into a
you know studio meeting and those studio
heads would be like oh we don't really
have any like jazz stuff or like you
know wow
yeah or they like send me
you know hip-hop stuff just because that
seemed like it probably made sense
and it was you know that kobe bryant
documentary is because my friend was
like you're a dope musician and i know
that if i give you
context and temp music and like we look
we talk about cliff martinez or philip
glass or steve reich or like that kind
of music that you're going to be able to
get that or you know justin simeon even
though a lot of that has jazz in it he
was also like i want jazz but i also
want ravel or i want like you know
things that feel like chopin or like
that kind of material
i feel like a lot of that
was uh really helpful in giving me the
experience to write in that way and same
with kobe actually kobe
for
his audio books uh
john williams was always his template in
his mind of of what
sound like and so you know the stuff i
had to write for that was trying my best
to write that harry potter type of style
of writing which he just meant like
studying those scores and studying how
to write in that style so like by the
time something like
bridgette came along which is like you
know completely this classical sound
right a lot of it was like
a combination of me always wanting to do
that uh also having having filmmakers
that gave me the space and trust to do
that just because like bridgette came
along because i had done a shonda land
show a few years ago that sounds nothing
like that and they just again trusted
that as a good musician i might be able
to figure that sound out and for me it
was all about studying that at the by
the time i got bridges and i i done so
much studying that i felt like much more
confident and comfortable in that kind
of space so like it's like i know people
i've always heard my whole life like
that i do you've probably heard that
like success is when preparation meets
opportunity
yeah yeah and so we are just like always
like how can i continue to prepare
because who knows when that opportunity
is going to come along yeah i mean if
you
i am
positive that shonda rhimes could see
like i feel like she's like this person
that cause she's all knowing and all
seeing she can
you know so she saw that in you and and
knew that and gave you that opportunity
and because oftentimes you go into
meetings like you said this um oh can
you write this hip hop song or can you i
love that um when people take chances
and that's how we blossom that's how we
grow that's how we we get to you know
just
stretch
i love that i love that
um so what questions do you ask yourself
that help you to decide the style of
score you'll be creating
well i guess if you know if it's
on a specific project most of that is
dictated by you know conversations with
the director like you know oftentimes
it's talking to
him or her about
like what they might uh
envision in terms of like what this
character listens to or
what kind of music is is uh happening
in this
uh environment or you know if there's
any music oftentimes directors i work
with were listening to music when they
were writing if they were also the
writer of the script so i often ask like
what other stuff have you been listening
to that's really helpful um
i also really love creating these
boundaries that i can then play in where
you know for a movie like king richard i
thought about the fact that
it might be interesting to pull elements
from this
world sonically uh thinking about like
the sound of tennis and the sound of
like the ball hitting the strings and
things like that and
yeah
like prepared piano or like all the
things that kind of maybe would create a
nice texture that made sense for me with
the film
yes so when you we we're talking about
like the kinds of films that like the
kind the sound that you're developing is
moving into classical it is classical so
when you
will you score other films like that
will take you completely out of that you
know how john williams has a sound are
you creating that chris power sound
i don't know i think you know
i often look at like you know john
williams i've
studied his career a lot and i think the
thing that was really fascinating for
him is when he was
around my age and like in his i'd say
like
20s to 30s he was doing a lot of like
studio work where he was just kind of
writing
the style of these different people and
you know i think also at the time
there was
you saw this old hollywood style of like
orchestral writing and things like that
but within that he was like writing all
these different versions of it and
really trying to like
write different types of music so i feel
like
i'm kind of in that period of my life
where i'm just open to whatever is going
to challenge me you know i think again
something else that kobe mentioned to me
a lot was like
think before you say yes to something
think about how that's going to
challenge you and make you a better
composer by the end of it and if you
feel like that's going to do that then
then take it and so often times even
projects there are often projects that
my team is like why are you doing that
and i'm like
i want to do it because you know it's
going to give me a chance to exercise
this muscle that i've never
had like before scoring space jam i
wanted to score raising dion because i'd
never done something that that demanded
like a bigger sound you know or like a
an action sound and so
me is just like what what's going to
make me better and how can i take those
things on to continue to grow so hope
maybe at some point i'll have like a
sound that's identifiable but i feel
like right now it's just i'm still in
studio developing yeah yeah yeah
that's that's amazing that you feel that
way
you know because you're you're you are
um
i i hear it i don't know how i miss that
you did raising dion i just it's i binge
watched it yesterday
part of i mean two days
two seasons wow
i had to check out and just like
re-center and i i did it with raising
dion so
that's amazing i love that kid it's just
like a such a cool i really love it um
so uh my next question is what's the one
film score that gets stuck in your head
i mean like there's definitely a lot i
mean
they're they're cliche just because
they're they are what they are i feel
like jurassic park and star wars are
probably two that that really stick in
my mind just because they're like
um
yeah just yeah listen to them so much
when i was a kid and and they were such
a big part of my
childhood and i feel like for all of us
it's such a nostalgic feeling that you
get immediately when you hear any of
those like chords or harmonies and also
the piano theme the flying theme from
from et is like
something that sticks with me so yeah
john williams is always my go-to
yes mine too i um i loved when i was a
kid i wanted to date two people when i
grew up and i was sure that i was going
to date e.t
we knew my mom was like okay girl
scooby-doo i'm gonna be with them when i
grow up
i watched a lot of movies and tv
um
so my next question is uh the director
has a new idea that contradicts an
earlier conversation that you had with
him
how do you handle those tricky
conversations without compromising your
own vision for the score
i think for me you know the vision is
whatever serves the story so like
there's so many times where i have
you know you take the time to come up
with a really clear vision for something
and then i take it to the director and
they're like no that's not it and then
you know for me i feel like
we are all trusting this director with
with the vision of what the story is and
the best directors are also trusting the
story to be
what it wants to be in to kind of like
you know following that as its north
star and so i feel like for me
whatever the director says is what it is
and so oftentimes a director changing
their mind for me has always led me to
a much stronger representation in the
music in the score where like you know
there are times where we're maybe
scoring a certain character in a certain
way and we realize that we need to be a
bit more complex or you know
not as one-dimensional with how how
we're doing that or you know by the time
we get
too far along into the film we realize
that like the way we've been scoring
this relationship or this character
doesn't pay off in the way we wanted to
so now we have to go back and try to
figure that out um and also at the end
of the day like we're all
humans like there are so many times
where like
i changed my mind about about like life
about so many different things like that
that uh you know
it's always about us being open to that
and i feel like allowing for that that
human aspect of of people feeling
differently once they've had time to
really sit with something only allows
for like better art
yeah and taking nothing personal i feel
um like in life and and film like
whenever i go into a project i know that
if someone says i don't want that or i
want this temp song like um just like
that i just don't take it personally and
also being willing to do as many
revisions as possible just because i
know it really gets better
um every now and again you know you made
like i missed the original version but
you i usually
really really
like the process of going
to to doing it over until it gets we get
it right yeah yeah yeah
yeah
so um how
do you find the film's musical language
and what about the film's repeating
motifs
so i feel like um
the motifs usually come from
you know once i've had those
conversations with the director about
what's most important to them um
we usually try to focus on those moments
and like for me
i'll always
watch the film through until i find a
moment that speaks to me on a visceral
level
where
you know with um
with green book it was this moment where
uh marshall's character don shirley was
like standing outside watching these
black field workers while he's being
driven by this white man and like you
see this this um
solitude in his eyes and like this like
change of sadness or pain and and that
was the moment that felt like
i feel like i can immediately write
something that maybe can like
get at that feeling and then that theme
was you know now his theme and now i can
look at any moment where
we want to work with his theme and try
to like you know put that in those other
places um same with king richard it was
like seeing this father
being told no over and over again and
then just keeping a brave face for his
kids and like continuing to push his
kids in this positive beautiful way
and
uh with that that was a moment that
really spoke to me and so once i had
that theme that was richard's theme so
then i go through and figure out where
else can we use richard's theme
and then sometimes when i look at
the other themes it's it's how does that
theme then play with the theme that has
already been established or
or you know what are we trying to say
with that character and kind of do the
same thing like you know thinking about
something like space jam it was this
relationship between lebron and his son
but also
uh algae the don cheeto character was
like all about ego and like
toxic masculinity essentially like all
these things and so you know i feel like
both of those worlds are worlds that i
could easily kind of put my head get
into that headspace and write something
from that place and then once i have
those themes that are really strong it's
just continuing to follow the story with
those characters or those motifs because
there are even times where you know that
character might not be present but
whatever we're talking about in that
scene might have to do with that
character and so you know using that
theme there and by the time i do that it
often feels like a lot of the movie has
kind of been scored at that point and
then it's about you know kind of filling
in the holes
yeah that's that's i okay so you just
hit us with like three
movies that i know i love so i'm sure
everyone watching does too
um i have a two-part question i think um
what musical story do you want to tell
like i know with like don shirley like
is there someone else that you or can
you even like share that like what
it could even be like the story of of
how a city feels to you it doesn't have
to be a certain you know what i mean do
you have a musical story that you
haven't told that you personally want to
tell
yeah you know i don't
they're definitely a lot of musicians
that i really would love to i'm just
curious about their lives and how to
tell that story like thinking about
um duke ellington or billy horn or
or lewis armstrong i think louis
armstrong is really fascinating to me
because i mean him and duke ellington
but there were these
these
icons and these like pop icons and
celebrities at a time where they were
also experiencing what it was like to be
a black man in this country in a way
that you know i just don't know how
louis armstrong was able to be as like
warm and uplifting and and such a
beautiful spirit and energy
you know for the rest of the world when
he was dealing with that personally so i
feel like those stories maybe as far as
musicians immediately come to mind yeah
um yeah i i see that for you
um
the other it's a fun question but i
don't know if you can really answer it
you have a favorite do you have a
favorite film that you've worked on or i
mean you've worked on tv and film but
film
do you have a favorite score
you know not really it's really like you
said it's really tough to answer that
generally it's it's
usually whatever is like the last thing
i worked on kind of feels like
i feel you know most connected to and
most proud of especially because it
always represents some sort of like
maturation or something so i do think
king richard in that way is probably
right now one that really like sticks
with me but there's always an element of
each one that i feel like proud of and
i'm sure the next one's going to be you
know my favorite
and that i'll tell you i want to see
that movie three times oh yeah
i'd every time like
no one was watching and they were
because like oh because it just pulls on
you in so many different ways just
beautifully
executed just beautifully written
beautiful all the acting everything was
amazing
um so the other question is um
the last question from this series and
we have like a couple more
how is composing for film similar or
different from composing for other
mediums like classical or jazz
performances
that's interesting i feel like
one is you know the fact that um the
film you are always a part of something
else and so
you know oftentimes
there are times where i might want to
do something because as a musician i
really want to like you know
kind of exercise an idea or like build
something out and kind of like make
something feel really big or whatever it
might be or busy and that's not going to
be the best thing to serve the the
action or the story or the moment and so
even though i love being an accompanist
as a film composer you're always that
and i think in the concert space
there's
nothing that you're accompanying in that
way in terms of like you know being able
to
uh write whatever and oftentimes that
can be a bit more difficult for me we're
like uh
thinking about a couple of classical
pieces i've written in the last few
years i've written a couple of concertos
and like
those are so difficult for me because
now every second is something
can be something else and like
oftentimes it's really helpful to have
something that you're accompanying
because then you're
just focusing on supporting something
instead of trying to like you know
constantly
think of how to fill the space um but i
think the similarity for me is also
always based in
storytelling and emotion where like even
as a jazz pianist
if i was improvising it was my turn to
to improvise
for me i always had to feel like what
like what is my mood right now what's
the mood of the space like what what do
i where do i want to improvise from
emotionally
um and that just became a north star and
anytime i didn't have that i just felt
like i was just
like playing
not connected to my heart it was like
mostly just like you know muscle memory
or playing for my brain
and i feel like even when i'm writing
something for that space it's the same
thing where i need to have some sort of
story or idea or emotion that i'm trying
to capture because then i feel like i
have a north star that i can go after
instead of just like writing something
to be like musically impressive or or
you know actually like an exercise
essentially yeah got it so what is your
favorite musical composition and what
makes it so good
that's a really tough question i think
um the answer i always come to is
uh luff's life lush life by billy
strayhorn which is
this really heart-wrenching beautiful
song my favorite recording of it is
johnny hartman and john coltrane
and
it's this like
sad song about a guy who lives a lush
life like lives a life at
drinking at dive bars and all that and
[Music]
i fell in love with a song and then
afterward learned that
billy strahorn was 17 when he wrote it
and
learning about like the pain that he
experienced as like a gay man a gay man
at that time he gave black man at that
time wow such a heaviness to that song
that's and it's still beautiful and it's
like a through composed thing that has a
journey to it so i feel like lush life
is always a song that i come back to hmm
i'm gonna have to check that out
um
okay so what mood is the hardest to
compose music for and why
you know i think the toughest move for
me is is um
like comedy or like levity
i find that
it's easy to
be
on the nose in a way where it's not very
interesting or it feels like very
expected and you know how to make
something feel funny
but feel unique to why whatever that is
is funny i feel like is something that i
always find
difficult because it's easy to just kind
of go through you know
pull out the pizzicato strings and
whatever else might be
like you know this is the funny sounding
music but to do it in a way that makes
it feel unique to that i think is always
something that's uh a bit more of a
challenge and isn't as immediate to me
or for me as a lot of other emotions
yeah i agree i did have fun with just
look up uh that was a
it was
i think it's the the world
the world was falling apart and i'm like
oh okay this uh there was inspiration
wasn't too far you know yeah turn the tv
on read the newspaper um yeah
so
what would you consider the most
challenging aspect of composing music
i think it for me it's myself like
getting out of my own way and like the
fact that you know the whole time i'm
writing music i'm thinking about how bad
it is or why i shouldn't be doing what
i'm doing or why i'm making a mistake or
you know i think the the stress of the
process for me
most of the time comes from the internal
dialogue i'm having with myself or my
fears of you know you're writing this
music for somebody else to say is good
so
then it's tough to like think about
whether or not what you're doing is is
going to please this other person you
can't really control that and
that's why it's always great to have
directors that create a safe environment
where you can feel not so concerned
about that but i do find that that part
of the process does
create this cycle for me with internal
dialogue that that um can be a little
tough sometimes i feel like that's
probably the hardest part is just like
getting out of my own way
yeah uh yeah move chris get out
sing that little song yeah
um so um describe a time when a musician
or director disagreed with you
and what happened
they want to know what happened yeah
what happened yeah
i mean like it happens most of the time
and i think that like you know
not most of the time actually that's
that's not true i think it happens quite
frequently and i feel like there are
there might be
maybe one time on every project you know
where that might happen where i feel
like i should go in a certain direction
and the director doesn't feel that way
but most of the time when i take their
advice
that ended up being the right way to go
you know one one very specific example
that i always find really interesting is
um
one of the very first score that i i
wrote was for um excuse me it was a
documentary for this woman elaine
stritch who um
the broadway
actress and
and um
she at the time she's passed now but at
the time she was still alive and she was
dealing with
diabetes and like had health issues very
frequently and she was in and out of the
hospital and there was a scene in the
documentary
where
the doctor was telling her she had a
really bad health scare and the doctor
was telling her how important it was for
her to take care of herself because of
how close she was to death essentially
and i wrote this piece of music that
felt like you know emotional and felt
like it was like had carried that that
level of
cautionary yeah caution yeah and the
director was like this is this feels too
sad this feels like she like she did die
like this feels like it's gone too far
in that direction
and
i wasn't really sure how to take that
and so i tried a couple other things and
it felt like we went too far in the
other direction where i didn't feel like
you know tense enough or didn't feel
like you know had enough caution and
the solution actually ended up being
changing the main instrument from piano
to um to a different instrument because
the sound of piano that made this moment
feel a bit too
sensitive or too yeah uh uh emotional
and so i feel like that was a moment i
feel really thankful to have had so
early in my career because that
immediately made me feel like oh
this instrument feels a certain way
especially for this director and so now
i know that like if somebody says
something's too sad it might not be the
piece of music it might just be this
game you know yeah that's that's a good
note can you explain how how you might
compose a new piece of work
yeah i think um
well do you usually sit down to piano or
i know i mean you're a pianist but
sometimes you pick up the guitar or no i
definitely don't pick up any other
instruments i wish i wish i could play
like me playing guitar is a very sad
song
[Laughter]
piano and other various keyboards but
other than that process i was mentioning
earlier about improvising and saying
yeah we're trying to improvise around
feeling oftentimes it's it's um
stepping away from an instrument
completely and just trying to think
about what that feels like and like
honestly kind of like singing to myself
for like thinking about sounds in my own
head where i feel like okay if i felt
this way like what does that sound like
and oftentimes i also started thinking
about what other pieces of music make me
feel that way like
so interesting for me to look at
there are a couple of pieces i
i know that um
directly influenced john williams for
example with like the sound of this
shaksakovic feature like the sound of
this other classical piece and the
emotion that it carried and then how he
was able to
totally do his own thing with that and
so for me i feel like
i've always looked at that as a piece of
reference where if i'm writing something
that's supposed to feel angry for
example then oftentimes if i'm stuck on
where to start i'll also think about
like what other music do i feel
makes me feel angry or like when i'm
angry i want to listen to because it
makes me feel like i can tap into that
emotion or whatever that is
and then i go listen to that music and
see if there's something about that
whether it's the tempo or something with
the harmonies or the melody or something
about that that is getting at that
feeling in a very acute way and then i
maybe try to borrow that element of it
and then build on that so sometimes you
know like i love this um
that video
it's on youtube and vimeo like
everything's a remix just because it's
like talks about how every every new
idea is not a new idea that's all right
something else and so
not being afraid of looking elsewhere
for inspiration because uh you know the
thinking that you have to reinvent the
wheel every time is right really stuck
yeah i have to look at that too
everything's a remix i'm not familiar
it's dope they literally do like a b uh
uh images of like you know um
star wars and like akira kurosawa films
or like star wars and like you know old
fighter jet films or like wow tarantino
and other like in westerns like it just
kind of shows how much people literally
take
frames from other movies as far as the
way they like shoot something or the way
that oh yeah costume and all that yeah
very cool
okay last question uh your composition
is poorly received and has to be revised
what did you do
well i feel like that was like
i was like wait which composition before
these
[Laughter]
for me i always try to get to
immediately to the
the solution like the answer like why
was it feeling that which because like
there's always um
you know like i i don't really sit too
long in the
um disappointment of that like i think
that honestly my
my trouble with like sitting in some
sort of like uh doubtful place happens
before i even share a piece of music but
like once i share something and somebody
tells me that this didn't work
uh often i'm like
like how
why why didn't that work well so i can
figure out like what to do differently
and asking those questions because
oftentimes it's like you know is it the
is it something about the emotion that
i'm missing is it something about the
pace of it is it something about the
instrumentation is it like you know
often times i'll ask the director if i'm
really far off if there's another piece
of music that does get to that feeling
for them or that they can think of
and
it's been really interesting sometimes
where i'll ask the director that and
they'll give me a reference that i'll
listen to and i'm like this this doesn't
sound anything like like what we're
working on
yeah or even sometimes like
sometimes our director is like
i think the sound of this this other
piece and because it has this
instrumentation and i listen to that
piece and it doesn't have that
instrumentation at all right yeah
oftentimes like i'm like okay well
there's something about this that made
you feel a certain way and so let me
look at that and is there anything about
this that i can borrow or figure out and
so usually it's just asking questions
like asking so many questions so i can
uh use this uh mistake or use this this
um
uh
you know yeah mistake for everybody yeah
yeah exactly a lesson so i can figure
out how to do something different and
move in the right direction yeah
absolutely so any final advice uh for
students getting into film composing
yeah uh
a few things i think
uh one always be
a student and be obsessed about you know
craft and getting better and learning
and that's all aspects of this job
because it's fascinating how much of
this job as a film composer can be
in the technical aspect of you know
knowing how to use
certain uh pieces of software knowing
how to actually record the music that
you're going to need to record or you
know make that music in terms of like
the technical part of that but also you
know knowing how to
express yourself with technical ability
i think is incredibly important because
technique only allows you to then
express yourself in a more fluid way um
and then the second thing to that is is
to really tap into
uh what it is that you love because
that's what makes you unique like it's
so interesting to me how much
i'll never forget like some of the
albums that i
found or feel like i found and
discovered that changed my life and then
i talked to somebody else about it and
they're like oh yeah and i'm like wait
how are you not like exactly
and
that that kind of taught me that like
the fact that that speaks to me so
deeply so personally uh means that
there's something in there for me to
continue to discover like figure out why
that's like a part of me that i'm
hearing in that piece essentially and so
whenever you recognize those moments
really hold on to those things and then
go deeper into those things um
yeah like those two pieces of advice
feel like the things that i always think
about myself even yeah great advice um i
just wanted to talk about a moment about
education being key because i know that
um not everybody has access and like
when i was growing up i i just didn't
want um just for transparency my mom was
a single mother
and my her best
what she wanted to do for me was to make
sure i survived east oakland california
and so
now looking back i have all this
information and whenever i have an
opportunity or an audience i like to
talk directly about education and how we
have the ticket to that freedom whatever
we want when we have uh when we go we do
well at school
can you speak to that
yeah 100 i feel like um
it's
really interesting how much
the way that our
systems have been built especially like
educational systems have been built to
make us feel like
you know
if you're not excelling that you're
you're
dumb or like you're not good at these
things
and in a way where it can be very easy
to like just give up because you know uh
you kind of accept this this um
prescription that that like the system
is kind of giving you even though a lot
of these systems have been built to to
allow that failure um and i feel like
you know really it's all about
uh being curious continuing to like move
at your own pace and like learn things
that at however you want to learn them
and
and like you said knowing that those
the more you do that the more you're
going to
unlock aspects of your future
you know it's pretty fascinating to see
how much
the world can change for you the more
that you
uh
feel educated in whatever space you
might want to be focused in or any of
that um and
yeah i feel like
knowing that like
anything that you're maybe feeling is
difficult
uh and that you're failing in like
you're not a failure like it's just that
something that the lesson yeah exactly
it's something to continue to chip away
and find the people in the and the
environment that's going to help support
that you know i think it's always
disappointing in spaces where like
uh the environment that you're in is
reinforcing these ideas that you might
not achieve something and that's just
not true like whenever i look at any
great person that i've either had the
fortune to be around or have studied
there's a book actually that i read
recently about greatness where it's like
it's a myth that people are born
great or born with these crazy talents
or born with these abilities that like
every person just spent much more time
than anybody else doing that thing
absolutely if you just spend time uh in
any space that you want to be great at
then you're going to be great and just
i totally agree knowledge is power yeah
it truly is it's our it's our um it's
our way up our way out our way through
yeah chris
this is amazing i love i could i could
have done this a couple of more
hours you know just amazing talking to
you and i and i hope to talk to you more
and
thank you
yeah for sure thank you chris for that
wonderful conversation and thank you for
participating in the academy's visiting
artist film series filmmate edition for
film composers and songwriters
you